Sí todo inició con dos tandas de cohetes
lanzados desde Siria los primeros desde
2019 hacia los altos del golán en
territorio anexionado por Israel tres de
esos proyectiles cayeron en espacio
abierto sin causar daños en ni víctimas
medios árabes indican que la
responsabilidad recae en una milicia
Palestina que opera en Siria y es aliada
del régimen de vallada y que es en
respuesta a las incursiones israelíes en
la mezquita de alaxa de ahí la respuesta
israelí que apuntó contra instalaciones
del ejército sirio porque en última
instancia lo responsabiliza de todo lo
que ocurra responsabiliza además o de lo
que ocurra en su territorio estos
ataques se fueron con artillería Y
drones no tripulados y e impactaron en
un complejo militar sistemas de radares
y de artillería en el sur de Siria
recordemos que Israel ha llevado a cabo
10 ataques en suelo sirio en lo que va
de 2023 Pero estos habían sido contra
posiciones iraníes o de sus milicias
aliadas y no los discute pública mente A
diferencia de esta ofensiva que realizó
una jornada de hoy y Federico este
domingo convergen también celebraciones
para las tres grandes religiones
monoteístas en Jerusalén como está
afectando esta situación a esas
celebraciones Y qué respuesta está dando
las autoridades israelíes
se ha multiplicado Obviamente el
despliegue de seguridad A partir de esta
convergencia que hoy encuentra a una
jornada importante de ramadán Pascua
judía y la Pascua cristiana El
despliegue es todavía mayor porque miles
de judíos se acercan al muro de las
lamentaciones para una bendición
sacerdotal vía anual que ocurre tanto en
Pascua como en sucot y cientos de ellos
también ingresaron en la Explanada de
las mezquitas que es un lugar reservado
para el culto musulmán según el statu
quo pero al que los judíos pueden
ingresar con la condición de no rezar
entraron acompañados Por un fuerte
cordón policial Y esto es visto como una
provocación por los palestinos de hecho
durante la noche cientos de hechos se
quedaron en la mezquita de alaxa Pero
esta vez la policía israelí evitó
desalojarlos por la fuerza y más allá de
algunas discusiones esta confluencia
terminó desarrollándose de manera
relativamente pacífica son numerosos los
frentes abiertos que tiene Israel de
tensión y es todo en torno a la
situación de la mezquita de araxa que
recordemos sufrió durante 12 noches
consecutivas incursiones de la policía
israelí que derivaron el intercambio de
fuego entre Israel y las milicias
palestinas en gaza y el sur del Líbano y
también en una serie de ataques que
terminaron con la muerte de 12 mujeres
israelíes y de un turista italiano